hi my name is Godwin also known as
Norfolk on the forums and part of my job
here at triumph is making levels in our
level editor for the game so today I
thought let's give you a preview of our
level editor it will ship with the game
and it will allow you all to make
beautiful maps you get the exact same
level
ultra as we have ourselves so you'll be
able to make pretty much exactly the
same campaign and the same things that
we have in our game let's start with a
bit of basics first I'm thinking let's
make some nice elven area here at first
we're going to sculpt the terrain make
it a bit nicer that's completely empty
of course when you start a new map we
can play some mountains here I've spent
more than the peaks get higher
automatically it's pretty nice so let's
see that's one don't feeling like that's
- one that's prettier
and then if it's large enough we can
maybe add some trees else love to live
in the forest Sun should be quite happy
with that some trees here maybe some
different trees in it I'm adding some
pine trees near the mountains that's
actually nice I think it looks nice
together we can make here a bit of a
rock for
mantas are falling down and of course
some water is nice make a little river
coming from behind the mountains and
flowing to a nice little lake here else
we're settling next to the lake because
they're like fish or maybe you don't fit
idiots like the water I don't know and
if we make sure that the river has a
narrow path to a bigger area of water
and you'll see automatically its suction
it starts to flow so that's also pretty
nice so automatic then of course or else
we'll need a place to live in so let's
see give it a structure city let's put
it right here right now it's all random
so every start time you start up the map
you get different races different size
we want it else so I'll just put down
here my ELF race and a size I'm thinking
maybe something like a city quite big
there we go nice elfin is it sitting
next to the forests the mountains and
some water
all right let's give some more
structures maybe a watchtower to look
over the water see what's on the other
side
and some mana notes of course else like
my Nisan sits next to water let's make
it a water notes of course some income
always need income so gold mines would
be good for that I like to place gold
mines near mountains because it sort of
makes sense in my hand if I can find
them I can search and recently this is
alright some gold mines here and yeah
maybe had some bit more a real relief
really I don't know the English word is
with some height differences make sure
that it's a bit more natural bit less
like pancake and maybe add a little road
going somewhere you can get around Lake
here going somewhere else hmm let's see
where does the road lead maybe it leads
to a goblin city in the neighborhood umm
let's place down the city first there we
go we select the race again resource
goblin village and goblins they actually
like to live in swamp they get a bonus
from that in game so let's give him a
bit of that they should be happy with
that
alright
and maybe some of these swamps to break
up looks and some more empty swamps all
right expansion well oh it looks good
swamps I think and near water actually
as well and then maybe some danger on
the road we want to go to the goblins
we must encounter a obsidian dragon
they're actually in-game they wouldn't
be visible since they are concealed in
the swamp so it will be nice surprise
for anybody following this road and
let's say that it's found a stash of
gold and it's guarding that already two
stashes know much all right that's
pretty nice now we need to give the
city's a leader since you'll be playing
a leader in if you make this just for
independence not a whole lot you can do
then so let's place them leader
somewhere in city
I can already give the city to our
leader of course we'll help and for the
goblins we'll give it to the other
player go player to city
and some units to defend themselves also
some normal units will spawn by default
if you just leave the city empty like I
did now they will get defended anyway
you will have to switch it off if you
don't want that so possible of course
actually not doing it the most efficient
way I can also change the player here so
that's for the elves start in starting
army longbowman in the trees and now we
might be ready to see what this can do
well maybe actually I will show you
something else we have a lot of
different climbs and it's really easy to
change the theme of the land just take a
big Brush rise choose convert to theme
and there you go things Arctic or things
volcanic you know that looks will
automatically be updated so let's not
ruin the nice else and just keep them in
temperates but let's make light its
swamps further the goblins
there we go so pretty easy to do
pretty simple lots of things to do can
also try to announce methods make it a
unique look we have a lot of different
decorations you can use for that maybe
some statues here your special ones for
in the corner there you go and so that's
the entrance to their domain we have
some torches two guards the swamp to
guard them from the swamp action um
there's quite a lot of decoration you
can place you can place some bikes with
skulls here for the goblins and maybe
some bigger bones here those creatures
have sunken in the city in there in
swamp and died there's some mysterious
mists maybe syrian dragon maybe his
breath causes the mist and there's some
lights we can put in here yeah so we can
now if we want try this out in game we
just click set in play and then we'll
launch the game and you can try to see
how it looks there
slowing a bit and then we should be able
to start our own city is here let's make
some troops
yeah we have our routes towards the
enemy so we can try that
oh there's the Obsidian dragon indeed
come shields all right we've shown you a
bit of the basic map editing to make a
level itself and now we can show a bit
more advanced stuff we have here the
settings the map settings yes these are
a lot of settings that you can set you
can customize quite a lot of things for
example whether you want to win
condition to be scripted only core
leadership just normal default where you
want to have the max hero levels etc you
know lock these as well feel what really
wants to prevent people from choosing
otherwise player she can set the
diplomacy between the player she can
change the piece fixed piece war fixed
Alliance fixed lines from neutral or
haven't met yet basically this means
they haven't encountered each other yet
you can do the same for cities
independent cities towards every player
so quite a lot of settings there and of
course you can also script map you have
for example markers you can add in stack
area trigger place it down and you have
here some settings the triggers on
everyone if you leave this empty or just
the players who sadly as you fill in if
you do that scripting is quite easier
just click this button making new
scripts here name it and for example if
you want to script to fire on stack
enter and you drag this here and if
stack enters it then whatever you type
here will happen language that we script
in is Lua so you can
probably find easy tutorials for that
online if you don't already know it so
it's pretty nice language to work with
so far yeah that's about scripting we
also have the campaign editor this is
the tool that we also used to make our
campaign you can add your scenarios that
you've made for example we just made
this test map so you can add it here you
can see as many as you like
now you can set a name description
there's also always room for custom
strings you can just type in there where
you want to show it's a briefing my
briefing page is like we have in our
game if you just right-click here add a
new page you can set an image here to
link so it's something in the background
you can type in the title name just the
normal story that you want to tell and
all kinds of things so I asked pretty
powerful tool to make campaigns and
we're looking forward to see you make
user made campaigns thank you for your
attention
you